kids are biggest way in which they're
not being prepared for the globalizing
world as they're not learning enough
they're not learning enough to be at the
top of their form and highly
accomplished and highly creative when
they grow up it's the failures of skills
and knowledge more than anything else
that is the failure of our system to
prepare kids for the globalizing world
there are kids learning enough about
other countries and other cultures well
you're never learning enough about other
countries and other cultures the honest
truth is though that the world is
learning English and we don't have to
have everybody in this country learn
Chinese they China is going to learn
English faster than we are going to
learn Mandarin and the we are fortunate
to live in a country where the primary
language is the is is the international
language as far as teachers from other
countries you can do some of that over
the Internet by having that that teacher
in Hungary or Bangalore deliver your
lesson over the internet all sorts of
teacher exchange programs take place and
a lot of school systems are now
recruiting teachers overseas frankly
they're recruiting them overseas because
they can't find enough competent than
math teachers in the United States
I don't think learning their language is
the way we're going to be one step ahead
of them I think we're going to be one
step ahead of them by having kids with
prowess in math and science and
engineering and with highly creative
minds not regimented and not super
disciplined I able to invent fresh
solutions to problems I think our way to
compete with China and I think we do
need to is going to be through a really
well-educated population not through a
population that has learned Mandarin I'd
far rather see the kids spend their time
on advanced algebra than on learning
Chinese language
you